[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d'information locale
sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi à 4
janvier tout de suite les titres de ce
set 8 journal et bientôt la fin des
vacances et vous ne pourrez pas y faire
quelques longueurs tout de suite le
centre aquatique du lac à montigny le
bretonneux est fermé pour travaux
jusqu'au 21 janvier
un chantier de renforcement de sécurité
du site et de changement des sols est en
cours
explications un changement effectif
depuis le 1er janvier la mission locale
de plaisir valgalier a rejoint à celle
de saint quentin en yvelines
une fusion absorption validé en conseil
d'agglomération fin décembre elle nous
recevons erwan le gall président de la
mission locale de saint quentin en
yvelines et des environs enfin c'est une
tradition du mois de janvier la galette
des rois et la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des yvelines remet
aujourd'hui le prix de la meilleure et
galette aux amandes du département nous
serons sur place à la fin de ce journal
politique également dans ce journal avec
une chronique à suivre sur l'avenir et
des républicains dans le département
c'est dans ce journal
un jour après le passage de la tempête
eleanor tout semble revenue à la normale
dans les yvelines d'après les dix plus
de problèmes d'électricité sur le
territoire hier pour rappel jusqu'à 4800
foyers du département avaient été privés
de courant et des rafales de vent à plus
de 100 kilomètres heure qui ont causé de
nombreux incidents notamment des chutes
d'arbres
le trafic de la ligne lui avait même été
stoppé toute la journée plus de 160
interventions des pompiers a dit blé
noir ont été nécessaires une pause plus
longue que prévu que d'habitude à
montigny le bretonneux en plus des
vidanges habituel des bassins deux fois
par an le centre aquatique du lac est en
travaux pour une quinzaine de jours
encore au programme remplacement des
éclairages ainsi que des revêtements des
sols des douches les détails de
nicolas kirillovitch une trêve hivernale
qui se prolonge pour le centre aquatique
du lac les bassins resteront fermés au
public jusqu'au 21 janvier
en cause les travaux entamés il ya dix
jours et qui prévoit notamment de
renforcer la sécurité et l'hygiène des
sanitaires avec l'installation d'un
nouveau sol
vasic est légèrement légèrement granit
et donc il va empêcher le
la glissade donc il sera plus sécure
aujourd'hui relevé au niveau des hauts
niveaux du carrelage sur la partie
douche ici donc le sol et l'ensemble des
murs va être revêtue alors qu'en fait
aux partenaires au niveau de la veste
hier ça sera uniquement le sol le
chantier permettra également de
remplacer la totalité des éclairages
dans et en dehors des bassins pour un
système plus économique
l'accès à la piscine est aussi repensé
avec une nouvelle billetterie
enfin les casiers sont remplacés les
monnayeurs sont abandonnés pour plus de
simplicité on va remettre des portes des
casiers plus traditionnelle
en fait avec uniquement le paiement fin
ce sera le la mise d'une pièce pour
avoir la caution et les personnes
récupéreront ensuite leur leur leur
pièce quand les catastrophes et quasi
vides il y aura une clé donc en fait
c'est un système tout à fait classique
coût total des travaux 430 mille euros
ouvert il ya quinze ans le centre
aquatique et fréquenté tous les ans en
moyenne par plus de cent mille personnes
les du nouveau pour la mission locale du
territoire depuis le 1er janvier les
missions locales de plaisir aval de
galié de saint quentin en yvelines ont
fusionné la décision a été validée lors
du dernier conseil communautaire
d'agglomération c'était le 21 décembre
dernier
bonsoir erwan le gall bonsoir d'être le
président de la mission locale de saint
quentin en yvelines et des environs vous
êtes également délégué à l'emploi et
l'insertion professionnelle à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus qu'une fusion finalement c'est une
fusion absorption puisque plaisir
intègre la mission locale de saint
quentin en yvelines
voilà en un an propres je serais quand
même présenter mes voeux en espérant que
cette année et 2018 sera une belle année
pour le territoire et une année de
cannes est en tout cas pour la nation
aussi une belle année qui est pas trop
de deux choses désagréables
voilà oui donc c'est une fusion
absorption pourquoi parce que
juridiquement c'était plus aisés ce
choix de faire des fusions absorptions a
été décidé il ya quelques mois parce que
nous sommes fait accompagner par un
cabinet mais la décision de
fusionner ces deux missions locales sur
le territoire à 12 communes et date
depuis 18 mois voilà donc j'en ai pris
la responsabilité de piloter ce projet
est officiellement il n'y a plus qu'une
seule mission locale sur les deux
communes
depuis le 1er janvier il n'y a pas eu de
créations finalement de nouvelles
structures la mission locale de plaisir
a rejoint tout simplement celle de 50 en
un an exactement
mais comme je comme je les dis de
nombreuses réunions c'est pas le gros
qui absorbé le petit c'est vraiment sur
un point de vue juridique
voilà l'antenne de plaisir existe encore
et elle existera encore voilà juste sur
sur le nom de la mission locale est ce
qu'il va changer est ce qu'on va rester
sur le nom mission locale de saint
quentin en yvelines et des environs
s'ils n'ont pas le nom de la mission
locale va changer nous sommes en cours
de réflexion
d'accord il ya eu un séminaire il y a
quinze jours trois semaines de cela
où l'ensemble des salarié e
on travaillé durant deux jours sur
trente questions 30 questions ont été
posées par les directeurs et les
présidents parce qu'il faut aussi saluer
le travail des directeurs des personnels
et aussi de mon homologue qui n'est plus
président de la mission locale de
plaisir mais qui est verni guernon qui
est maintenant vice présidente ce sera
la fin qui va être élue vice-présidente
ans s'est pas encore effective dans les
faits c'est comme ça que ça devrait se
passer parce que je tiens à saluer son
travail parce que nous avons travaillé
de concert tous les deux voilà est
cordialement et avec eux une vision qui
étaient très claires et politiquement
clair sur le territoire voilà il ya eu
trente questions au niveau de ses
séminaires dont une quel est le nom et
il faut un nom dynamique il faut casser
les codes de la mission locale
peut-être y revenir après sur une de
questions parce qu'à lille sur le call
et un regard maintenant qui est mal
perçue dans l'esprit des jeunes et
auprès des entreprises donc voilà il
faut convenir oui après d'ailleurs aux
internautes vous a demandé leurs idées
concernant le nouveau nom de la mission
locale on a eu un certain nombre de
choses on a demandé aussi aux salariés
depuis un bout de temps quel est le nom
qui le souhaiteraient il faut il faut un
axe vraiment dynamique qui est qu'ils
soient cohérents centre territoire 1 il
faut que le jeune arrive sur la mission
locale ou le nom qui s'y retrouvent
c'est à dire que pour lui c'est clair il
ya c'est la porte d'entrée pour trouver
toutes les solutions peut-être pas lui
les solutions qu'ils souhaitent rapide
en tout cas qui n'ont plus à porter
qu'est ce que ça change concrètement
pour le jeune justement d'avoir une
mission locale plus élargie avec un
territoire plus grand on l'a dit les
douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
puisque intégration de delà de la
mission locale de plaisir qu'est ce que
ça change mais vrai pendant de temps le
premier temps qu'est ce que ça change
c'est que il va falloir être
sur le territoire très clair c'est à
dire que la mission locale absurde qu'un
certain nombre d'actes et de chantier au
niveau de l'emploi et et d'autre part
toujours de l'emploi mais il ya d'autres
enjeux et ne faut pas que les deux
communes reproduisent en écosystèmes par
rapport à ça la porte d'entrée c'est la
mission week end voilà donc lui il va
s'y retrouver john parce que on va pas
démultiplier les actions
ça c'est apprendre chose deuxième temps
c'est que la mission locale et la fusion
hawk cette grosse mission locale parce
que elle va être la quatrième plus
grosse de la région d'île-de-france
d'accord 3 millions de budget d'accord
c'est pas une mince affaire cette
histoire mais il n'est pas question de
se faire plaisir en disant voilà on a
réussi quelque chose là en fait
juridiquement et comptablement on a
démarré quelque chose et on a fini
quelque chose on redémarre autre chose
sauf que nous allons partir sur un
projet d'établissement sur quatre ans
avec des axes donc il ya un certain
nombre de dax je voudrais citer de sade
et 2018 dans les axes ils ont ainsi il y
aura une durée dire que l'accès x il a
jusqu'au mois de juin pour être mis en
place et un autre axe il aura peut-être
un an et demi ou deux accords voilà mais
l'enjeu c'est d'avoir le projet
d'établissement décrit clairement et
dans les accès d'avoir une meilleure
visibilité auprès des entreprises
allaient auprès des entreprises et aider
les entreprises dans leurs recrutements
etc
c'est là où le jeune homme s'y retrouver
c'est à dire que nous on va aussi être
un style tu représentes reprise mais ça
pour le moment on ne sait pas le faire
deux dernières questions sur les
missions locales l'émission quel service
apporte l eau aux jeunes et à qui
s'adresse-t-elle est ce que ça à tous
les jeunes que s'adressent ces missions
de narcé
16 25 ans d'accord et également tous les
jeunes oui enfin partout moment il ya
une souffrance où il ya un problème où
il ya c'est une porte d'entrée enfin
d'accord 10,85 à partir de à partir de
là oui on peut répondre à nombre de
choses
logement la santé on peut on a des
partenaires partenariat pardon avec la
sécurité sociale pour la carte vitale et
ces voix là et plein d'autres choses
dernière question il nous reste moins
d'une minute sur le territoire de saint
quentin plusieurs antennes un siège pour
cette mission locale et prieur antennes
réparties sur le territoire
oui et un siège qui restera là willy
pour le moment l'autre antenne une autre
antenne qui sera sur guye en cours
uniquement pour la garantie jeunes et
puis plaisir qu'il a existé et j'ai
juste oublié de dire a lancé dans ses
antennes
on va faire un fab lab c'est à dire que
on va mettre en place une entité où on
va évoquer un certain nombre de
problèmes sur le territoire pour le
jeune il y a déjà des gens de
l'université qui vont ils rentrer qui
sont intéressés des gens de l'entreprise
n'a qu'un également voilà merci avec
nous président de la mission locale de
saint quentin en yvelines et des
environs je précise d'ailleurs nous est
déléguée à l'emploi et l'insertion
professionnelle à saint quentin en
yvelines et pour plus d'informations sur
la mission locale de saint quentin en
yvelines et pour prendre rendez vous
notamment avec un conseiller vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran on reste à
saint quentin en yvelines a identifié
des pannes de chauffage et centraliser
les informations sur la consommation
énergétique des bâtiments publics c'est
le système dont s'est dotée la commune
de guyancourt est depuis novembre les
bureaux du centre technique municipal
sont équipés de cette technologie
reportage de nicolas landry contrôler la
consommation d'énergie des bâtiments
publics à partir d'un ordinateur central
c'est le système mis en place par le
service technique de guyancourt un
dispositif développé dans le cadre de la
politique de développement durable de la
ville investissement initial de la
commune 150000 euros avec à la clé des
économies d'énergie l'objectif est
d'économiser entre 20 et 30% de
kilowattheures consommés on ne parle pas
forcément de valeurs financières parce
que le prix de l'électricité hui ou du
gaz peut évoluer
par contre on parle d'économie de
kilowattheures consommés en un clic à
partir de cet ordinateur l'utilisateur
peut baisser la température est indre la
lumière d'un bureau ou identifié un
dysfonctionnement de modules de
régulation du chauffage et de
l'éclairage
un système installé dans les bâtiments
du service technique à l'école de
musique et à la batterie
nous pouvons voir donc sur le module
chauffage les températures dans les
bureaux les si les fenêtres sont
ouvertes ou pas puisque dès que
la fenêtre est ouverte la gtb couple
chauffage nous pouvons voir
effectivement tout de suite le matériel
qui est utilisé s'il fonctionne bien
les températures modifier les
températures à notre guise et à distance
et cette centrale d'air pilotés à
distance depuis le centre technique
municipal se situe dans l'école de
musique de guyancourt c'est notre
chauffage en fait de l'auditorium
en fait on a impulsé de l'air sous les
pieds des l'auditorium prochaine étape
l'équipement de l'hôtel de ville et de
la piscine par ce système et le
développement de nouveaux modules comme
la gestion de la consommation d'eau et
vous avez entendu sa voix sur ce sujet
est avec mon plateau nicolas landry
bonsoir bonsoir grégory de la rédaction
de tv 78 vous allez nous parler
politique
à présent après les revers essuyés lors
des présidentielles et des législatives
les républicains entre dans une phase de
refondation est laurent gonthier laurent
wauquiez a été élu à la tête du parti de
droite avec +2 74% des voix quasi
plébiscite aussi dans les yvelines où il
frôle les 68% nicolas dans quelle
situation se trouve le parti dans les
yvelines et bien grégory actuellement
les républicains une lingua sont dans le
flou dans les faits c'est même un parti
sans président départemental même si
david douillet occupe toujours
officiellement ce poste mais depuis sa
défaite aux élections législatives
il a pris ses distances avec la vie
politique aujourd'hui c'est la sénatrice
sophie primas qui est aussi secrétaire
départemental du parti qui gère la
fédération yvelinoise alors l'élection
de laurent wauquiez a entraîné le départ
de plusieurs élus dont xavier bertrand
pour ne citer qu'eux que lui qu'en
est-il dans les yvelines
alors en fait dans les faits les
réserves à paraissait déjà avant
l'élection du président des républicains
le maire de poissy karl olive émettait
des réserves vis-à-vis du parti avec le
maire de saint germain en laye arnaud
péricard il a même créé un mouvement
génération terrain mais l'initiative
pour la présidente du conseil régional
ile-de-france valérie pécresse
avec son association libre et alors
après le scrutin et l'élection de
laurent wauquiez
quelques militants et binoy n'ont pas
hésité à quitter le mouvement mais c'est
une vraiment une minorité et écouter
pierre bédier
résident du pré du conseil départemental
des yvelines et flora sabbagh présidente
des jeunes républicains et binoy c'était
vraiment les principaux soutiens de
laurent moqué dans le département il
reste quand même rassurant écoutez à
l'heure actuelle les jeunes sont plutôt
dans le flou au niveau du département
puisque nous sommes dans une dans une
zone d'incertitude on ne sait pas encore
comment va se recomposer la fédération
néanmoins l'élection de laurent wauquiez
à la présidence de notre famille
politique avec un large score leur
redonne de l'enthousiasmé de l'espoir
valérie pécresse a ses idées très bien
qu'elle les exprime au sein de notre
famille politique qui a vocation à être
plurielle et à rassembler diverses
sensibilités et ça aide toujours été la
vocation de notre parti que d'avoir une
aile plutôt sociale libérale et une aile
plus tôt gaulliste social je regarde
avec beaucoup d'intérêt
le mouvement concret valérie valérie
pécresse si c'est effectivement un
mouvement à l'intérieur de l air pour
exprimer des idées pour faire que ces
idées soient majoritaires c'est parfait
si c'est à nouveau pour faire du
fractionnisme on sera dans l'opposition
encore très très longtemps mais on
finira par disparaître alors l'a entendu
nicolas on comprend que le défi pour
2018 sera de rassembler cette famille
politique du centre et de la droite est
ce que le tableau est aussi assis noir
dans le département la situation n'est
pas non plus catastrophique dans les
yvelines si la fédération connaît des
difficultés
il ya quand même les élus locaux qui
font qu'ils font la force du parti
encore un succès politique comme vous le
savez en septembre lors des sénatoriales
une majorité au conseil départemental ou
encore quelques grandes agglomérations
du département sous l'étendard des
républicains conseiller municipal
d'opposition attrapé président du groupe
les républicains et indépendants au
conseil régional vous l'avez reconnu
c'est othman nassr ou croient en leurs
la reconstruction de sa formation à
partir du territoire la gestion qui est
celle des yvelines du département danse
à travers deux collectivités nombreux
dans ce département la les scènes et les
saluer par par les habitants et les
maires qui sont en place qui sont des
mères souvent des maires de droite sont
reconnus pour la qualité de leur travail
cette réalité là elle est toujours là
elle est toujours en vigueur et c'est ce
que c'est le socle de ce qui va nous
permettre peut-être demain de rebondir
et de dire voilà ce que c'est que d'être
de droite parce que c'est que de
travailler d'être engagé comme un
citoyen comme élu local dans les
yvelines
l'élection du prochain président les
républicains dans les yvelines est
prévue pour octobre 2018 certains
imaginent déjà une candidature de pierre
bédier
merci nicolas pour cette chronique on
trouve tout de suite à un autre
journaliste de la rédaction de tv 60 18
mai à versailles michael et milo qui
après nous avoir parlé de régime détox
hier va déguster de la galette
visiblement les bonnes résolutions ne se
tiennent pas longtemps
vous êtes michael à la chambre de
métiers d'artisanat
les yvelines elle remet actuellement le
prix de la meilleure galette aux amandes
du département et oui grégory je suis
sur tous les fronts comme vous pouvez le
voir aujourd'hui c'est le concours de la
meilleure galette du 78 et à mes côtés
le président olivier gérard
olivier gérard comment fait-on pas
remporté ce type de concours qui se
passe justement derrière nous oui
bonjour à tous c'est un très bonne année
gourmande à tous les yvelinoises et
holistique du noir qu'elle veut dire oui
et donc sur le sur le cadre d'un
événement très cesti ce donc le concours
de la meilleure baguette aux amandes
discipline commandes et comment
découvrir la meilleure galette des idées
il est déjà allé chez les 20 premiers là
qui sont énumérées mais personnellement
du bon beurre de la bonne farine de la
bonne poudre d'amandes de bons voeux et
un tour de main séculaire donc ils
étaient une soixantaine c'est ça au
début du concours
oui nous avions 30 30 chefs d'entreprise
et 30 salariés est dedans nous dans
l'eau dans les salariés y avait
également des affres des jeunes
apprentis seconde année deuxième année
et le but c'était le but est évidemment
c'est de promouvoir l'artisanat et de
promouvoir le savoir-faire de savoir
être de nos artisans boulangers
pâtissiers de manier chaque jour de
bonnes matières 2 offerte excellent
produit et d'excellentes d'excellentes
pâtisseries et en l'occurrence là la
meilleure galette aux amandes désigné et
comment fait-on pour évaluer une galette
alors cette année nous avons la chance
d'avoir un d'avoir un jury éclectique
nous avions deux champions d'europe
monsieur maxime monsieur damien de d'un
boulangerie la noce à paris qui est
champion d'europe
viennoiseries nous avions également
monsieur maximilien têtard si les
champions d'europe pièce artistique qui
est qui et comment
qui est à
qui est chez una bourgeois nous avions
également un jeune monsieur conrad à
monsieur conrad grana qui est également
juste manger là losc et qui est meilleur
jeune boulanger de france 2016 et au
niveau des critères à leur niveau des
critères donc évidemment la présentation
parce que la vue fait la vue fait la vue
fait évidemment donne envie je veux dire
nos cinq sens sont mis en éveil et ce
qui est extraordinaire c'est ça c'est
que les cinq sens de l'être humain
c'est dire font apprécier une bonne
galette donc et ensuite nous avons la
cuisson il y a la garniture
avec son goût l'équilibrage donc le
qu'est ce que l'école a coupé
l'équilibrage c'est d'avoir une osmose
entre eux la pâte feuilletée et la
garniture et puis évidemment la cuisson
est celui qui a remporté le prix cette
année c'est une boulangerie de noisy
loin si je me trompe oui entendu juste
derrière pendant qu'on était en
interview oui c'est monsieur barberaz
caprices de roy ainsi que son salarié
qui termine premier également qu'est ce
que ça lui apporte
je pense que là il peut courir tout de
suite dans sa boulangerie pour justement
mettre en oeuvre dans son laboratoire de
nouvelles galettes pour demain et pour
les trois semaines qui vont suivre
parce que ce qui est formidable c'est
que cet événement est relié par nos amis
journalistes est évidemment une
publicité extraordinaire
combien de pourcentage en plus de
galettes vendues sur un mois alors lui
il peut multiplier par trois sa canne et
c'est ça je le premier oui les deux les
deux précédents oui c'était ça c'était
multiplié par 2,3 vrai on lui souhaite
en tout cas évidemment avec grand
plaisir
merci beaucoup voilà grégory je vous
laisse moi je les déguster à des
galettes
merci à michael régalez vous et avec
patrick et jacques de dixmude aux moyens
techniques
suite et fin de notre fil rouge de la
semaine nous revenons sur les faits
marquants qui ont marqué l'année 2010
est le dernier épisode ce soir sur la
période septembre décembre une heureuse
nouvelle pour la france et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
changements dans la politique locale et
plusieurs disparitions d une
rétrospective le montage de cette
rétrospective est signée xavier jallais
l'événement de la rentrée par il
attendait son temps après la capitale
organisera les jeux olympiques d'été en
annonce officielle suivie en direct au
vélodrome nationale l'enceinte est l'un
des quatre sites de l'agglomération
choisie pour accueillir à des épreuves
c'est vraiment une explosion joie on a
senti lors de l' annonce est maintenant
l aventure commence une aventure
commence c'est une aventure historique
et ça va être passionnant de vivre cette
période
dernière grande échéance électorale de
l'année les sénatoriales les
républicains conduits par ray gérard
larcher réélu ensuite président de la
chambre remporté cinq des six sièges
possibles
l'un est obtenu par michel laugier
touché par la loi sur le non-cumul
il a dû quitter ses mandats de président
de saint quentin en yvelines et de maire
de montigny le bretonneux
c'est un mélange de fierté et de bonheur
et de tristesse aussi parce que j'ai là
un clip dit si pâle qui est dynamique
cette fin d'année a été également
marquée par le retrait de deux femmes
politiques yvelinoise toutes deux
anciennes ministres
la socialiste catherine tasca ne se
représentait pas aux sénatoriales est la
fondatrice du parti chrétien démocrate
christine boutin démissionné de sa
fonction de conseillère départementale l
assister à sa dernière séance le 21
octobre à versailles
après 35 ans de mandat c'était très beau
7 c'est très très beau je voulais
absolument rien mais j'ai été très très
touché par l'authenticité c'est un
changement qui de fait est douloureux
parce que moi j'ai beaucoup aimé le
sénat octobre mois des frondes politique
mobilisation notamment des élus pour le
maintien de la ligne à 18 dans les
yvelines
c'est aussi le mois des changements de
visage jean-luc ourgaud devient maire de
montigny le bretonneux
jean michel fourgous édiles d'elancourt
prend la tête de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ouverture
prônée quatre vice présidents seront
accordés à l'opposition de gauche qu'on
puisse tous partir dans le même sens là
donc c'est la première tâche qui
m'incombe dans le dans les quatre
semaines à venir
du nouveau également à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines le
professeur alain but est élu président
il succède au professeur didier
guillemot démissionnaire pour raisons de
santé
fin 2010 est marquée également par la
révélation de la fair value stein
quelques semaines plus tard en novembre
le centre d'information sur le droit des
femmes et des familles des yvelines fête
ses 35 ans la parole se libère mais déjà
depuis plusieurs années on voit qu'il ya
de plus en plus de manifestations
enfin de dénonciation de faits on le
voit au niveau du nombre d'augmentations
de nos victimes aussi des exploits et
des performances sportives en nombre de
records du monde
à 82 ans jeannette augusto réalisé 28 km
226 en une heure sur la piste du
vélodrome nationale 24 heures de nage en
apnée pour randy cabreira davila saint
cyr l'école pour le téléthon en décembre
la 6e place à la transat jacques vabre
pour le skipper versaillais tanguy de
lamotte qui a permis de sauver 25
enfants malades du coeur et puis il est
en cours toit a dit la mohammadi qui
conserve sa ceinture européenne de boxe
lors du mail et 24 au vélodrome et
encore merci pour ceux qui le
soutiennent
de la joie mais aussi de la tristesse
avec des disparitions le maire de
chevreuse claude jeunot fin août est
l'acteur jean rochefort en octobre qui
laisse un souvenir fort à auffargis où
il possédait un haras et bien sûr johnny
hallyday en décembre le chanteur a
habité les yvelines mais aussi donné un
concert et l'encours en 1990 je dis qu'à
l'habitude au grand palais des sports 20
à 30000 personnes 50 mille paires locaux
ils ont bloqué à 2000 places pour des
raisons de sécurité déjà à la toute fin
de l'année les yvelines embarque dans
une galaxie très lointaine avec la
sortie de star wars 8 et c'est le petit
village de gars lui qui crée l'événement
en proposant une exposition tricot
insolites autour de l'univers de la saga
une exposition qui se poursuit jusqu'à
fin janvier l'embarquement pour 2018 est
enclenché avant de refermer ce journal
attention si vous empruntez la ligne l
du transilien le trafic sera perturbé ce
week-end ainsi que celui des 13 et 14
janvier aucun train ne circulera entre
les gares de versailles chantiers et
paris montparnasse est la raison des
travaux à hauteur de la gare de clamart
dans le cadre du grand paris express
pour vous rendre ou revenir de la
capitale vous pourrez néanmoins emprunté
les lignes y et c'est notamment
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal vous
retrouvez demain le 7-8 l'hebdo avec
nicolas kirillovitch ainsi que le 7-8
loisirs présenté par camille lambert
quant à nous on se retrouve dès lundi
prochain pour une nouvelle édition
d'information locale sur tv 60,18 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]